♪ ♪
>> Sean: NEW AND EXPLOSIVE
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT SURROUNDING
HUNTER BIDEN'S HARD DRIVE FROM
HELL AS PETER SCHWEIZER, WHO'S
BEEN REVIEWING THE MATERIALS ON
THE LAPTOP, HE CONFIRMED TO ME
THAT MATERIALS ON THAT HARD
DRIVE PROVE JOE BIDEN WAS A
DIRECT BENEFICIARY OF HUNTER'S
NEFARIOUS FOREIGN DEALINGS.
REMEMBER, JOE REPEATEDLY SAID HE
HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF HUNTER'S
DEALINGS.
HE SAID IT REPEATEDLY, I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE WAS OVER, NEVER ONCE
SPOKE TO HUNTER ABOUT IT, BUT WE
HAVE PICTURES SHOWING HIM
MEETING WITH, YEP, HUNTER'S
BUSINESS PARTNERS.
WE HAVE EMAILS SHOWING HUNTER
WAS SETTING UP MEETINGS BETWEEN
FOREIGN BUSINESS PARTNERS AND
HIS FATHER WHILE HE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AND REMEMBER THE
REVELATIONS FROM TONY BY
BELINSKY, CAME FORWARD AND SAID
THAT HE MET WITH JOE BIDEN AND
TALKED TO HIM ABOUT HIS BUSINESS
DEALS WITH HUNTER.
JOE WAS LYING.
AND WHILE JOE WAS VICE PRESIDENT
THIS WAS ALL GOING ON AND IT
DOESN'T STOP THERE BECAUSE
HUNTER 'HAS ART DEALINGS, BY THE
WAY, ARE STILL SHROUDED IN
SECRECY.
WHAT IS THE MARKET FOR THESE
PAINTINGS?
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE GREAT ART
TO ME.
WHO ARE THE BUYERS?
WHY ARE THEY BEING KEPT SECRET?
IS THIS MORE INFLUENCE PEDDLING
FROM THE CORRUPT BIDENS
SYNDICATE BUSINESS BUREAU?
REMEMBER THERE IS STILL A CABAL
OF DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS INSIDE
THE FBI, THE SAME FBI THAT
ILLEGALLY SPIED ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DO WE REALLY EXPECT ANY SERIOUS,
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION INTO THE
BIDEN FAMILY CRIME SYNDICATE
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE FBI?
HERE WITH REACTION, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JASON CHAFFETZ.
DEVIN, LET ME START WITH YOU,
CONGRESSMAN, ON THIS QUESTION.
YOU ARE ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ME OR EVEN CONGRESS
MENTE FITS -- IF SOMEBODY BY THE
NAME OF
ERIC TRUMP JR. OR ERIC TRUMP GO,
LET'S SEE, RUSSIA AND THEN
LATIMER PUT GOT AWAY FOR AN OIL
PIPELINE -- I'M MAKING THIS UP
AS I GO AT THE SAME TIME THAT
TRUMP WAS CANCELING THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
AND IMAGINE IF LET'S SAY THAT
$1.5 BILLION DEAL WAS WITH ONE
OF THE TRUMP KIDS AND AT THE
SAME TIME OUR MILITARY BASES
WERE BEING THREATENED BY THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE AND THE
REUNIFICATION WITH TAIWAN WAS
BEING TALKED ABOUT AND -- YOU
KNOW, IF THESE THINGS WERE
HAPPENING AND IF DONALD TRUMP
LEVERAGED A BILLION DOLLARS TO
GET A PROSECUTOR FIRED WHO WAS
INVESTIGATING ONE OF THE TRUMP
SONS, I DON'T KNOW, I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST INVESTIGATIONS WOULD
BEGIN.
WOULD YOU IMAGINE THE SAME?
>> WELL, SEAN, THAT STORY SOUNDS
AWFULLY FAMILIAR.
I THINK SOMEBODY ACTUALLY DID DO
THAT.
AND I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT IT
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT IF
THIS WAS ANY REPUBLICAN, THIS
WOULD BE A MASSIVE POLITICAL
SCANDAL OF ONE THAT WE'VE REALLY
NEVER SEEN.
AND DON'T FORGET, RIGHT BEFORE
THE ELECTION, THIS WAS
SUPPOSEDLY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
IT WASN'T JUST BIDEN WHO SAID
THAT.
IT WAS OVER 50 TOP INTELLIGENCE
AND MILITARY OFFICIALS WHO ALSO
SAID IT.
AND I THINK AT SOME POINT YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHERE THESE
FORMER OFFICIALS AND THE BIDENS
AND THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN, WHERE
THEY COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA?
WHERE THEY COLLUDING WITH CHINA
TO HELP COVER THIS UP USING THE
FAKE NEWS AND USING THE TECH
OLIGARCHS WHO CENSORED THIS?
THOSE OF THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO GET
OUT THERE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO EXPOSE THIS CORRUPTION AND
WHAT IT REALLY AMOUNTS TO, I
BELIEVE, THAT THIS REALLY SWAYED
THE ELECTION, BECAUSE ANY TYPE
OF SCANDAL LIKE THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN BLOWING UP BEYOND BELIEF
BEFORE AN ELECTION IN OCTOBER.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU'RE FRIENDS
WITH HIM, WORK WITH
PETER SCHWEIZER, JASON CHAFFETZ.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THIS HARD DRIVE
EXISTS, BUT YET NOTHING SEEMS TO
BE DONE ABOUT IT.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE THERE IS A BIT OF A
COVER-UP GOING ON AT THE MOMENT.
REMEMBER I AM A DISTINGUISHED
FELLOW AT THE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNT
ABILITY INSTITUTE, I DO WORK
WITH PETER BUT WHAT HE'S DONE IS
HIS CROSS-REFERENCED SOME OF THE
DATA FROM HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP
WITH THE FBI -- OR THE
SECRET SERVICE RECORDS RELEASED
BY SENATOR JOHNSON AND ANOTHER
BUSINESS ASSOCIATE WITH HUNTER
BIDEN.
SO THEY ARE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT HERE,
BUT THERE IS DIRECT EVIDENCE
THAT JOE BIDEN HIMSELF -- JOE
AND JILL BIDEN TOOK DIRECT
BENEFIT BY USING ASSETS AND
THINGS THAT WERE PURCHASED BASED
ON THE TRANSACTION THAT HUNTER
BIDEN WAS INVOLVED IN AN ENGAGED
WITH WITH THESE FOREIGN
ENTITIES.
REMEMBER HUNTER BIDEN HAS HAD
PROBLEMS WITH RUSSIAN
PROSTITUTES, HE'S UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION, HE SEPARABLE WITH
GUNS, HE'S HAD TROUBLE WITH
DRUGS, HE'S TAKEN MONEY FROM THE
FORMER MAYOR OF MOSCOW'S WIFE IN
TUNE OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
HE HAS FLOWN ON AIR FORCE 2 WITH
1 OF HIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATES.
HOW DOES A BUSINESS ASSOCIATE OF
HUNTER BIDEN FLY ON AIR FORCE
TWO TO GO TO MEXICO CITY TO SET
UP A DEAL?
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THE LAST OF
THAT.
HE'S ALSO FLOWN ON AIR FORCE TO
TO CHINA AND THEN HE HAS THESE
UKRAINE MONIES FLOWING END BY
THE TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL SCANDALS THAT WE HAVE
EVER SEEN AND IT'S BEING COVERED
UP BY THE MEDIA, IT IS NOT BEING
INVESTIGATED AND THE FBI
CERTAINLY IS DOING ITS PART TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS INFORMATION
DOESN'T GET OUT THE DOOR.
>> Sean: AND WHERE IS JOHN
DURHAM, CONGRESSMAN NUNES, I
WILL ASK WHERE HE IS, BUT IT
WILL ALSO ASK WHERE IS
ADAM SCHIFF?
>> WHILE I DON'T REALLY CARE
WHERE ADAM SCHIFF IS RIGHT NOW.
I DO CARE ABOUT JOHN DURHAM, BUT
SEAN, THE OTHER QUESTION WE NEED
TO ASK IS TO JASON CHAFFETZ.
HE SERVED WITH ME HONORABLY, HE
WAS OVERSIGHT CHAIRMAN AT
ONE POINT, BUT I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY JASON IS NOT IN
THE ART BUSINESS BECAUSE I HEAR,
JASON, THAT YOU CAN GET 500,000
BUCKS FOR -- I KNOW YOU'VE NEVER
BEEN AN ARTIST, LIKE ME, BUT
THIS IS ANOTHER MASSIVE SCANDAL.
SO TO JASON'S POINT, THIS WHOLE
ART DEAL -- IF ANYBODY CONCOCTED
THIS, THIS WOULD BE ANOTHER
MASSIVE SCANDAL.
NOBODY JUST GETS OUT FROM
NOWHERE A LOBBYIST AND THEN THE
DRUG ISSUES AT ALL THIS AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT'S LIKE I'VE
ALWAYS WANTED TO BE AN ARTIST,
LET ME JUST SELL IT FOR, LET'S
SAY $500,000.
>> Sean: WE'RE GOING TO -- I
ACTUALLY AIMED AT PORTRAITS OF A
AND IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE
FINGERPAINTING AND IF I CAN DO
IT, IT'S NOT ART.
TRUST ME, I HAVE NO ARTISTIC
ABILITY.
LAST WORD, JASON.
>> THERE WAS RECENTLY A VAN GOGH
PAINTING THAT WAS DISCOVERED,
AND GUESS WHAT?
IT WENT UP FOR AUCTION.
FOR $150,000.
IT WAS ONLY ONE-THIRD THE PRICE
OF A BIDEN.
YOU CAN GO GET THE PRICE OF A
BIDEN, HAVE ACCESS TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU THREE
TIMES MORE BUT IT'S HONESTLY
WORTH A LOT MORE THAN ANY VAN
GOGH OUT THERE.
>> Sean: IT OF COURSE IT WON'T
BE MADE PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE A RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH, A CHINESE NATIONAL,
THE CHINESE MILITARY, A
KAZAKHSTAN OLIGARCH, OR MAYBE AN
EXECUTIVE FR